what were some of the big takeaways the
events still under way some of the big
takeaways us for updates to the Mac
operating system the new iphone software
has some new a new news reading
application a new kind of digital
assistant improvements to maps that
improvements to Siri the voice assistant
and with some details about the new
strips are also going to be coming later
in the presentation Adam I want to
follow up on that because there's so
much attention focus on this new music
streaming service Apple is pretty late
to this game on music streaming what's
the biggest obstacle that it needs to
overcome yeah that's kind of a theme of
this overall event so far a lot of the
things that Apple's been introducing
have already different offerings have
been available from different companies
and music one of the biggest challenges
is going to be showing what's different
about what they're doing and obviously
they have a lot of money at their
disposal they can partner with a big
name artist like you two to get the word
out and I think they're really going to
be going after customers who aren't
necessarily Spotify and other streaming
services customers now they're going to
be trying to get people who haven't done
a subscription streaming service in the
past and so we'll see how that shakes
out soon as we get some more details
here in the next hour so Adam is this
about AB Apple trying to put its stamp
on music streaming or is it feeling the
pressure now coming from the youtubes
and the Spotify of the world I think
it's a little of both an apple has
obviously a rich tradition in music the
ipod is basically what turned this
company around but as well the music
business is changing that going from a
download model where you pay ten bucks
you get an album and you store it on
your device to now the streaming model
which
Spotify Pandora YouTube where you can
just listen to things on demand through
an internet connection and so Apple is
both trying to maintain its leadership
in music but also try and shift with
where the market is going so it's
shifting where the market is going but
why is it important for apples even be a
strong player and streaming beating
Spotify and Pandora is great in terms of
headlines and buzz but it's not
financially significant to a company
like Apple is it it's a great point i
mean the grand scheme of things the
music is a is a miniscule part of apples
business of what what they really need
to do is try and that they want to sell
iphones that's the biggest part of their
business and so with a music service i
think the idea is that it becomes a
little more sticky that someone will be
less likely to move to a dif different
by a different phone if you can buy a
phone and get three months free with the
beats music as is
that they're going to be announcing
later today that might be an enticement
to get an iphone these everything is
with Apple is sort of centered around
you need to sell more iphones that is a
huge part of their business Adam a
couple of things that caught my interest
before we let you go Apple's saying that
it's going to take apple pay to the UK
next month and also its renaming
passbook to wallet what's the
significance of these two changes the
pay apple pay being changed to wallet
it's just a sort of an evolution of this
product this is so you can use your
phone or your Apple watch to buy things
in the store and this is a new business
that Apple's been getting into over the
past year other companies have been
there before like paypal and google to a
certain extent but again this is Apple
trying to take advantage of its scale
there's hundreds of millions of iphones
that have been sold and so if they can
get the customers who already have these
phones to start using their payment
system or the music service then they
have a really built in sort of customer
base that they can build from